I want to give you some good news check
this out
according to CNBC US savings rate hits
record 33% as coronaviruses caused
Americans to stockpile cash and curb
spending look what Bank of America says
here at the bottom
Bank of America says somewhere here here
we go
Bank of America which touches half of
Americans households said checking
accounts have 30 to 40 percent more
money in them compared to 12 weeks ago
CEO etc etc etc okay so now let me give
you another data here till Melanie comes
out to savings watch this you'll be
blown away by this this is the savings
rate since 1960
America on average we were saving 10%
then we went up to somewhere around
seventeen and a half percent in 1978
then it went down and down and down in
our Bahamas sitting there too good in
about 30-40 years we were saving
somewhere around 5% hit a low of 25% in
2006-2007 and then look boom 33% so now
what does this tell you it tells you we
used to be savers then we became
spenders because of a lot of TV
marketing and hey let's buy luxury
luxury luxury luxury luxury luxury and
then BOOM oh my gosh it's not really all
about luxury maybe just maybe cash is
king
maybe we need more cash you know in the
bank well maybe we need more cash in
case a crisis takes place and people are
right now sitting there saying you know
what I hope they're thinking about the
same if I can save 33 percent during
these times let's just say I'll go back
to regular life what was i spending
money on that I don't need to spend
money on what was I buying that I don't
need to be buying what was i purchasing
that I can set aside for now and what if
maybe I can't be at 33 percent when I
get back to normal life well maybe I can
figure out a way to it that 15 percent
marker because if you hit the 15 percent
marker of saving your salary you're on
your way to creating wealth
you
[Music]